هذه البيانات التي تصدر عن حزب الله ل
ننظر بشكل مفصل بالبيانات التي تصدر عن
اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بهذه الجبهه تفضلي
فاطمه نعم ليلى اذا بما يخص التطورات
الاخيره هنا في الجبهه الشماليه نتحدث عن
اصدار الجيش الاسرائيلي بيان بما يتعلق
باستهداف مدينه كريات شموني بصاروخ مضاد
للدروع اطلق من الاراضي لبنانيه طبعا هذا
الصاروخ كان قد انفجر وسط المدينه في شارع
جدا حيوي في كريات شمونه حتى هذه اللحظه
وفق الاسعاف الاسرائيلي لم يتم الاعلان عن
اصابات ووفق التحقيقات الاوليه التي
اجراها الجيش على المستوى الميداني تبين
ان هذا الصاروخ كان يريد ان يستهدف نقطه
لتجمع الجنود في وسط المدينه ونحن نعلم ان
البلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه منذ بدء هذه
المواجهه في الثامن من اكتوبر تحولت الى
مناطق عسكريه مغلقه وايضا كان قد نصب في
مداخلها ومخارجها جهه حواجز للجيش
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي اصبحت هذه الاماكن
جميعها مواقع عسكريه يتم استهدافها من قبل
حزب الله وبالتالي هذا يعني عمليه نستطيع
القول بانها نوعيه انه سقط صاروخ وسط هذه
المدينه دون تفعيل صفارات الانذار ايضا في
المقابل الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه رد
على مصادر اطلاق هذه الصواريخ عبر استهداف
مواقع عسكريه وبنى تحتيه تابعه لحزب الله
في جنوب لبنان وقبل دقائق قليله فقط كنا
نسمع اصوات الانفجارات العنيفه الناجمه عن
القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي الذي يطال
البلدات الحدوديه الجنوبيه وايضا يعني كان
هنالك استهداف عبر الغارات الجويه وايضا
عبر المسيرات الاسرائيليه التي تم اطلاقها
نحو مواقع عسكريه يقال بانها تابعه لحزب
الله ومن تلك المواقع يتم اطلاق العمليات
باتجاه البلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه هذا
ايضا ياتي في خضام تبادل اطلاق الصواريخ
في الليله الماضيه ما بين الج الجيش
الاسرائيلي وما بين حزب الله نتحدث ايضا
عن استهداف فندق في بلده المطله الحدوديه
في الجليل الاعلى وايضا استهداف كريات
شموني بالصواريخ ومواقع اسرائيليه اخرى
واللافت
هو ازاله حظر النشر الذي كان قد فرض على
استهداف القاعده الجويه ميرون في جبل
الجرمق والتي تم استهدافها باكثر من 60
صاروخا كرد اولي على عمليه اغتيال صالح
العاروري الجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه كان
هنالك اضرار قد لحقت في هذه القاعده
للمراقبه الجويه ولكنها تعمل كما هو معتاد
دون ان يفصح حول ماهيه هذه الاضرار ولكن
باللافتات هذا الموقع وا لحقت به اضرار تم
اطلاق منطاد للمراقبه وهو لاول مره يستعمل
منذ بدء هذا الحرب وهو لربما يكون مؤشر
على مدى الاضرار الذي لحقت في هذه القاعده
الجويه لذلك نستطيع ان نرى على المستوى
الميداني هنالك تبادل للقصف الصاروخي ما
بين اسرا ما بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وما بين
حزب الله وايضا على مستوى التصريحات
الاسرائيليه لازال الموقف الاسرائيلي على
حاله بضروره تغيير هذا الوضع الامني هنا
على الجبهه الشماليه هنالك ترقب لما
ستحمله زياره الوزير ال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن وهي الزياره
الخامسه والتي من المتوقع ان تناقش بشكل
معمق منع تدهور الامور هنا في الجبهه
الشماليه من مواجهه محدوده نوعا ما الى
حرب شامله مع لبنان وهذه تطلعات الاداره
الامريكيه هنالك محاولات لان يتم الضغط
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه بالتقيد بهذه
المواجهه وعدم اندلاعها نحو حرب شامله رغم
المطالب الاسرائيليه بتوسيع هذه المواجهه
و بازاله التهديد الصادر عن حزب الله عبر
الخيار العسكري وعبر دافع عناصر الرضوان
الى ما بعد حدود نهر الليطاني وبالتالي
يتمكن اكثر من 70 الف اسرائيلي بالعوده
الى منازلهم اشكرك جزيلا فاطمه خميسي اذا
من الجليل الاعلى ش